the alien movies are some of the
scariest and best-looking sci-fi horror
movies ever made unfortunately while the
xenomorph Queen might be unkillable it
doesn't look like the franchise has
quite the same luck here's why we're
afraid that alien 5 might never make it
to the big screen when Ridley Scott
revealed that he was developing prequels
to alien it was a huge day for fans of
the franchise but maybe we shouldn't
have gotten so excited 2012 Prometheus
wasn't exactly a disaster but the
numbers had posted at the domestic box
office were a cause for concern a king
has his reign and then he dies the movie
failed to recoup its 130 million dollar
budget domestically though success in
overseas markets just about made a
sequel viable 2017 alien covenants wound
up underperforming both critically and
commercially however leaving the status
of the franchise in jeopardy
Scott was open about his plans to start
filming a sequel within a year of
covenants release but it doesn't seem
like the box office returns were good
enough for him to get a green light from
the studio of course no more alien
prequels doesn't necessarily mean no
more alien sequels but confidence and
interest in the series is low following
covenant echoing the fallout that
followed 1997's disasters Alien
Resurrection the franchise was put back
into hypersleep for years and the same
could be happening right now
a chart geders contribution to the Alien
franchise has been well noted but Scott
is of the belief that Geiger's iconic
creation has now lost its ability to
scare audiences
he told Hollywood Reporter that I think
that beast has almost run out personally
you gotta replace that the franchise is
named and based around the existence of
this vicious alien so if it just isn't
scary anymore is there even any point in
making an alien 5 it was terrifying in
its day but maybe it's possible that it
takes more than a creature from outer
space to excite audiences
meanwhile one of the biggest complaints
alien fans had with Prometheus the lack
of Xenomorphs he's got attempted to
remedy that with covenants bringing the
alien back for another go
despite the directors earlier claims
that the creature wasn't scary anymore
it was a fickle move that didn't go
unnoticed by fans or critics after the
film flopped he reverted to his original
stance and stressed that he wanted the
franchise to explore artificial
intelligence I don't understand I guess
that's because I'm a human being
hey you're a robot and even though he
did bring the Xenomorphs back in
covenant much of the focus remained on
Michael Fassbender xandred David Scott
even clarified that any further prequels
would keep the focus squarely on the
androids Scott laid out a vision for a
planet led by David but that vision
sounds closer to Blade Runner than it
does alien the further the franchise
drifts away from its roots the less
likely it is will ever see round 5 of
Ripley vs. the xenomorph while alien
films could still be released under the
Fox studio name in the coming years
they'll probably be made under the
supervision of its soon-to-be parent
company Disney alien is one of the many
properties that Disney will have access
to when it fully completes its takeover
a Fox which is a cause of concern for
some Ridley Scott included speaking to
Digital Spy the veteran filmmaker
expressed concern over what rating any
future alien movies would shoot for I've
been with Fox for a number of years now
I'm hoping I'll still probably be there
so whether or not Disney go ahead with
such a dark subject as aliens remains to
be seen
Disney's got a lot of franchises it's
juggling at the moment the Marvel
Cinematic Universe continues to dominate
Hollywood and Star Wars isn't exactly a
small franchise either that's not even
mentioning any of their many other films
and projects all of which might get in
the way of pushing out more Alien films
anytime soon Disney has a lot going on
and it will no doubt be wary of messing
with alien canon whether that be scouts
prequels or any potential sequels Ridley
Scott isn't the only director who could
have made alien v Neill Blomkamp the
director of district 9 was in talks to
direct a sequel that would have picked
up immediately
aliens avoiding the baggage from alien 3
and resurrection pole Sigourney Weaver
and Michael Biehn would have returned as
Ripley and Hicks and being even floated
the possibility of new coming back as a
27 year old woman can I dream yes honey
I think we both can fans hope that this
long-awaited sequel would inject some
new acid blood into the fading franchise
so what happened in two words alien
covenant
Blomkamp said that preparation for a
sequel really got going in 2015 this was
around the time that Ridley Scott had
just finished his work on critical and
commercial sci-fi smash the Martian
leaving him with an open slate waiting
to be filled this effectively gave the
studio a choice and they sided with
Scott's prequels over a Blomkamp sequel
in January 2018
Blomkamp tweeted out that the alien 5
project was 100% dead and buried and
that he had moved on to other work
there's a really good reason that Neill
Blomkamp wanted his movie to take place
after James Cameron's aliens the first
sequel to Ridley Scott's original 1992's
alien 3 was trashed by the majority of
critics who praised director David
Fincher for taking some admirable risks
but concluded that too few of them paid
off in this plot hole riddled script why
did the ship crash land if the ship
sensors picked up the fire then why
didn't the ship's sprinkler system
activate how did the egg even get on the
ship after the events of aliens alien 3
left us with more questions and answers
and the very premise of the movie was
dubious Alien Resurrection was only
slightly better received with a story
that made little sense and a bizarre
escalation of the classic alien design
in fact the most impressive and
memorable moment in resurrection belongs
entirely to Sigourney Weaver for sinking
a basketball through the basket behind
her back
without the help of special effects
[Music]
Ridley Scott ignored all alien films not
directed by him when he began work on
his prequels and 2017 s covenant more or
less erases them at this point nobody
really knows where alien 5 would fit
into all of this when he revealed that
Hicks and newts were potentially
returning in Neil Blomkamp's planned
alien 5 Michael Biehn also suggested
that Sigourney Weaver would be bowing
out in favor of a new lead who would be
able to carry the franchise going
forward speaking to icons of Christ in
2015 bean said that they're planning on
bringing me and Newt back and at this
point Newt will be around 27 years old I
know that every actress in Hollywood is
going to want to play this one it's
really a passing of the torch between
Sigourney and this younger actress who
would play Newt it would keep the
franchise alive and the studios would
make money because that's what the
bottom line is now money plane it Beale
frankly I made a movie it doesn't look
as though Newt will be returning anytime
soon but being is right about one thing
money talks in Hollywood and franchise
longevity is key we're bringing
Sigourney Weaver back for another run
out as Ripley achieve that it would
probably be easier for Disney to simply
wipe the slate clean and start over with
the Alien franchise putting the prequels
original series and any chance of an
alien 5 to bed in fact prior to the
acquisition deal with Disney Fox was
reportedly planning on doing just that
but who said the reboot had to be on the
big screen
fresh rumors of a TV show set in the
alien universe emerged in April 2000 18
it was welcome news for fans after
Blomkamp's alien 5 died but things went
quiet in the months that followed making
the rumors seem less like insider
information and more like eager fan
predictions bucks was never likely to
greenlight an alien television show with
the Disney Deal looming large however
now that the merger is basically a done
deal
Disney might just go ahead and do it for
them we know that Disney is heavily
investing in an upcoming streaming
service in an effort to establish a
foothold in the Netflix dominated field
the new service will boast original
Marvel and Star Wars shows when it goes
live in 2019 and adding an alien series
to the mix could only add to the hype it
might not be alien
but you may be seen more of your
favorite acid blooded deadly xenomorph
Queen sometime soon on the small screen
get away from her you [ __ ]
[Music]